es ist die größte automobilfabrik der
welt volkswagen in wolfsburg
diesel affäre betrügereien und jetzt
tierversuche die skandale um den konzern
reißen nicht ab
jedes mal heißt es das wird konsequenzen
haben
doch das gegenteil ist der fall vw hat
eines der erfolgreichsten geschäftsjahre
seiner firmengeschichte hinter sich über
10 millionen vw fahrzeuge wurden im
vergangenen jahr weltweit ausgeliefert
ein plus von rund 4 prozent
doch wie kommt das was macht die marke
vw so stark dass die autokäufer ihr
trotz allem weiter vertrauen
[Musik]
antworten darauf haben die profis in den
marken agenturen wie hier in berlin bei
metadesign volkswagen ist einer ihrer
kunden genauso wie porsche eon oder
siemens starke marken dem skandale
offensichtlich nur wenig anhaben können
seine marke die denen die menschen
vertrauen und warum vertrauen sie eher
weil sie wird die aufgewachsen sind weil
sie ein teil ihrer situation gewesen ist
weil sich vielleicht sogar einen teil
ihres eigenen aufstiegs war und die
marke war immer im kern einen teil der
der inneren gesellschaft denn des kerns
der gesellschaft die menschen haben über
die jahrzehnte hinweg ein unfassbares
vertrauen in diese marke aufgebaut also
das depot was aufgebaut worden
das ist riesig groß
natürlich ist volkswagen nicht ganz
unbeschadet geblieben
in den usa musste der autobauer bis
jetzt 25 milliarden euro strafe zahlen
und auch wenn der absatz insgesamt
steigt in europa gerät vw bei den
dieselfahrzeugen unter druck hier ist
der dieselanteil im jahr 2017 um mehr
als acht prozent in spanien gesunken in
deutschland um rund sieben prozent
wir haben das mal als tainted love also
enttäuschte liebe bezeichnet und genauso
ist das verhältnis zwischen volkswagen
und das ist wieder kind war das kann man
wieder richten aber es bleibt ein
erstmal ein misstrauen und dieses
misstrauen ist sehr tief volkswagen muss
versuchen da jetzt gegenzusteuern
meta design hat im auftrag von vw eine
kampagne entworfen die den autobauer als
digitalen dienstleister in szene setzen
soll
autos die per app mit smartphone oder
tablet vernetzt sind so soll die zukunft
aussehen
zugute kommt den unternehmen konsumenten
sind vergesslich oft sind die affäre nur
ein sturm im wasserglas und haben keine
langfristigen folgen
beim autokauf spielt das
umweltbewusstsein ohnehin kaum eine
rolle
laut umfragen des deutschen
automobilclubs adac steht auf platz eins
die zuverlässigkeit auf platz 2
sicherheit gefolgt vom raumangebot dem
design und der marke das
umweltbewusstsein kommt erst weit hinten
auf platz 24
auch diese berliner agentur ist auf
strategische markenkommunikation
spezialisiert
zu ihren kunden zählt unter anderem die
deutsche bank und die telekom deutsche
konsumenten sind marken besonders treu
in einer studie wurden sie 2017 befragt
welchen marken einer branche sie am
meisten vertrauen bei den automobilen
was volkswagen auch marken wie nestlé
gelten als vertrauenswürdig obwohl der
konzern in diverse lebensmittel skandale
verwickelt war
oder die textilkette c&a die in
billiglohnländern nähen lässt die marken
halten dann scada -skandal auch wenn sie
sich ihnen auch stellen und das
nachvollziehbar und transparent und wenn
sie dann aus dieser analyse des der
krisen situation heraus glaubwürdig
aufzeigen dass sie ähnliche effekte in
der zukunft vermeiden wollen marken
vertrauen kann erschüttert werden
es darf nur nicht mehrfach erschüttert
werden das ist der wesentliche punkt
aus der diesel affäre scheint vw noch
einmal davon gekommen zu sein
doch hat der konzern mit seinen
abgastests an tieren und laut
zeitungsberichten sogar menschen eine
neue schwelle überschritten